a client brought me this bottle about
four years ago it took me about 20
seconds to tell him that it was
unquestionably a counterfeit bottle wine
fraud is not new
unfortunately it's pretty safe to say
that anybody who's been collecting and
buying wine in the last 15 years they
have probably purchased at least one
counterfeit wine we manage private wine
collections for individuals people who
are just starting to collect all the way
up to people who have tens of millions
of dollars worth of wine but we also
specialize in authentication of fine and
rare wine which is where I get the
nickname the Sherlock Holmes of wine it
sounds really hokey but the first thing
that I do is I just spend a couple
minutes like just looking at it and
taking it in one of the things that I'm
looking for in any given bottle is
consistency so in my toolkit I have
magnification flashlights blue lights
and razor blades the composition of
paper and a glue have changed over the
years and there are chemical additives
that have been put in and depending on
how something reacts under a blue light
you can date it this bottle is supposed
to be from 1947 it flores's this paper
should be totally nonreactive
to a blue light if it were true to its
periods but it is not magnification is
useful to see paper grains the quality
of the print the type of the font and
the size of the font I'm looking for
sharp lines these sharp lines are going
to be the result of proper printing
whether it's offset letterpress or some
other type of professional printing we
don't have this kind of fuzzy noise of
all the splatter from an inkjet
length of the cork is something that
counterfeiters get wrong all the time so
I do a lot of measuring this actually
has an authentic label and this is
supposed to be an 1861 note Bree on the
problem is that the cork is completely
blank and hope round would have never
done that I have to say that I have no
worries about this bottle I mean it
looks totally fine
and this happens to be one of the few
Italian wines that is kind of frequently
counterfeited this is embossed as it
should be
the paper has a nice texture to it a lot
of times
counterfeiters can't afford to use or
they don't use proper gold foil and so
it won't look this pretty you have to
have looked at tens of millions of
dollars of real wine to be able to spot
a fake it can be really brutal to tell a
client that they've got fake one so I
kind of have to treat it like taking a
band-aid off it's like BAM that 82
Petrus that you have is actually
counterfeit